alors excusez moi vous déranger alors
voilà je suis face à un gros dilemme
j'ai un choix cornélien appel parce que
je prépare ma mort j'ai envie de te
paraît d'abord donc j'ai le choix entre
un circuit dans les lycéens et à
certains emplois zélande
alors je vous avoue jamais vu
esthétiquement c'est toi qui es tu avec
le pin des landes c'est ma région mais
j'ai quand même du mal à choisir il sent
qu'il avait préparé vêtements est ce que
est ce que la part mise à jour le vent
la marque qui ont déjà vécu une première
ça scientiste
oui dole s'est pas beaucoup moins bons
coups avec une conversation de cette île
est justement jamais qu'une conversation
de ce type parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'on parle pas beaucoup plateau et je
me suis baladé sur un des matelas
maintenant et j'ai vu que six cent mille
personnes étaient décédées
rien qu'en france l'année dernière
justine henin à peu près d'une personne
sur 110 soit d'une personne morale ça et
puis après j'y mets et ses défunts il
avait peut-être une famille voire un
certain dan ce qui fait que le nombre de
personnes affectées par la mort la
dernière n'est pas ce sens il est
peut-être malheureusement j'ai pas trop
les chiffres alors c'est un sentiment
que partage donc crise il n'est pas
d'accord mais j'ai l'impression que
comparativement au manque de personnel à
bord tous de presse
moins bien c'est un sujet peu avant et
alors on nous a demandé pourquoi je me
suis posé la question un petit peu de
temps j'ai trouvé trois annonces
la liste n'est pas exhaustive restait la
banque aidée par vos raisons et selon
moi la première
si le tableau sociétale je gagne vie
sociétale parce que c'est difficile car
elle part d abord à d'autres gens par
exemple moi j'aurais du mal à l'époque
et china de ma mère sa grand mère voilà
j'ai l'impression une pente abrupte en
ce moment donc tous les endroits où tu
préfères de ton futur parricide à dire
ça la deuxième raison que j'ai trouvé
c'est le terme que je qualifie de
personnage
c'est à dire vers la mort j'y ai déjà
pensé mais jamais ou bien elle fait peur
ou ça m'évoque une personne qui les cd
et en vinyle et la cuisine maison
si le manque d'intérêt pour tout le
monde jeunes générations on a pris pas
la mort c'est un peu le dernier woody
allen chances d'atteindre avant donc la
mort j'ai un tout petit peu penser à
rome continue le speech la géantiste à
l'heure en levant la main aussi en
levant la main qui a déjà ressenti une
de ces trois jours voire plus voir
d'autres ne pas parler tableau ok voilà
quel pouvoir pour cent ça ok et bien
parce que ce sont des bonnes raisons la
parade avant l'arrêt la critique et
d'acier et je me suis dit mais alors
essayé on a dit bon résultat parisien
la mort c'est juste parce qu'ici on
pourrait arriver là oui je vais vous
aider à la diffusion parce que j'avais
pressenti mauvaise et mangez pas trop
soucieux comme ça j merci fort mal et je
me suis rappelé comme guillaume a
mentionné tout à l'heure que j'allais
mourir et que le débat seule la mort
conditionne entre nous à mourir et nous
le savons mais 26,6 avoir conditionne
notre vie comme ça peut-être qu'elle
était créé certaines actions au
quotidien par exemple pourquoi est-ce
que je regarde par notamment de
traverser ou pourquoi certains ce pauvre
durant leur guise se demande qu'est ce
que je vais faire de ma vie
il ya un peu de conscience de la mort
derrière ça un petit peu mais sûrement
mais alors ça veut dire qu'on aurait
besoin de parler d'abord puisque cette
mort peut expliquer certaines de nos
actions version vous nous connecte en
parle mais alors devenir le démarre
entre mais c'est à dire qu'on a besoin
de parler d'abord et à la cantate bwv on
en parle on ne part pas à toi comme
septième titre à l'e3 pour cette super
intéressant que joue génial et qui
s'appelle le développement rejoint
pourquoi ne manquent pas
premièrement tout le monde connaît qui
est d'abord de parler d'elle et
deuxièmement le niveau de jeunesse
sacchi des valeurs ont décidé de mettre
de plus en plus de nos actions
quotidiennes de plus en plus voire même
en entreprise et en gris moshi ou non un
tympan
c'est pas le sujet de la discussion ce
que je trouve généralement durable c'est
que ça nous permet d'apporter de
nouvelles pistes de réflexion voire même
nouveau métier
je pense leur emploi permet faits et
parce que le développement durable
heureusement comme ça pour nous
permettre d'attraper la mort d'une
nouvelle race je n'ai pas conclure à ses
valeurs
on pourrait parler d'amour on pourrait
commencer après un bond à jour non pas
comme un tabou bon je reconnais
souffrance non pas comme un élément qui
n'est pas digne d'un tel mais comme un
des plus grand acte d'humanité pour
l'empreinte environnementale peut être
vite c'est sexy normes comme ça sexy est
passé d'à priori ou d'un congrès à son
enfance à notre bord on est obligatoire
sommes dans un cercle et obligé c'est là
le ensuite on a le choix entre la
génération
la crémation des exhumations l'antenne
et puis la crémation et l'inhumation
sont des procédés qui ont une empreinte
environnementale particules fines d'un
côté dans l'air et trace
environnementale sur le sol pendant deux
mois années je crois y aurait par
quelque chose de plus durable à voir là
dedans alors pour les quelques vocations
qui commence à naître dans la salle
j'envoie les pompes funèbres futurs
ouvriers les pompes funèbres
eh bien j'ai un truc pour vous mais pas
que pour vous car j'ai une bonne
nouvelle
il ya déjà des personnes qui ont pensé à
ça et des initiatives fleurissent un peu
partout dans le globe mais pour la faire
court je vous en citer deux la première
ça se passe en france en partie il ya
des entreprises qui créent qui fabrique
des cercueils à base de cellulose
recyclée plus communément appelée
cercueil en carton
il serait plus léger plus écologique à
la fabrication j'utilise le conditionnel
est aussi serait plus écologique lors de
la description la destruction l'autre
processus que si je peux qualifier ainsi
que je trouve très intéressant
c'est quelque chose que j'appelle lui
mutations que j'appelle pop excusez moi
j'appelle passé que les autres qui
l'appelle comme ça
utilisation l'humiliation c'est assez
simple c'est le fait de poser le corps
d'une personne décédée bien entendu sur
terre de la recouvrir de matière riche
en micro-organismes qui procéderont au
fil des saisons à sa décomposition
en gros une mutation compost humain
c'est un peu ça en résumé alors ces
initiatives je les trouve très
intéressante premièrement ce ne sont pas
les seuls loin de là et deuxièmement je
ne veux pas en faire l'apologie
je suis pas expert du tout rien à voir
enfin genre expérience par contre ce que
je trouve génial derrière ça c'est
qu'elle apporte de nouvelles pistes de
réflexion
un peu comme le développement durable et
qu'elle permette d'envisager la mort non
pas comme je disais tout à l'heure comme
un tabou mais comme un bel acte
environnementale dix ans mais alors
certains d'entre vous me dire ou es bon
c'est sympa ton truc la mort plus écolo
ok sauf que j'ai l'impression que tu
réduis la mort un processus dont
l'empreinte environnementale peut être
réduite
sauf qu'entre nous la mort c'est pas que
ça et ceux qui pensent ça aurait raison
de le dire car c'est vrai la mort est
bien sûr un phénomène physique notre
corps se décompose nous mourrons et tout
ça mais c'est bien sûr aussi un
phénomène social de tout temps depuis
que nous sommes humains nous entourons
nos défunts des défunts que nous avons
aimés de leur vivant et que malgré leur
mort on s'en fiche de ça on continue
d'aimer la mort et l'amour sont
fortement liés et si cet amour perdurer
heureusement qu'il est là cet amour
heureusement qu'il est là et merci
perdure après le décès d'une personne il
conviendrait peut-être de penser que cet
amour ne nous détruise pas trop penser à
une mort
socialement plus durable et pour
répondre à ça je vous propose à tous de
préparer votre mort débute alors bon je
vais pas vous laisser comme ça je vais
pas me barrer va pas faire ça il vous
parlez d'un exemple personnel concret
papa je pose le truc
l'année dernière mon père est décédé un
peu plus d'un an et je ne pense pas je
ne pense pas qu'il ait prévu sa mort ni
même préparer sa mort en revanche ce
qu'il avait prévu
ce qu'il avait pensé est-ce qu'il avait
partagé à mon frère est à moi furent
deux souhaits le premier il voulait pas
se faire intérêts jamais dans un certain
soutien
on a conduit qui voulait se faire
incinérer le deuxième souhait fut
l'endroit exact où il voulait que nous
déposions ses cendres et je pense que
j'ai pas besoin trop vous expliquer que
le fait d'avoir su ça avec mon frère
nous a premièrement enlevé un poids mais
surtout nous a permis de vivre une
cérémonie puis proches de lui ont ça
correspondait à ses volontés en quelque
sorte
sauf que gros carton rouge pour lui il
nous avait dit que ça ouais
du coup on est arrivé à l'hôpital avec
mon frère on arrive et puis le médecin
il est arrivé il a dit ladite bien mieux
que ce que je vais vous dire mais j'ai
dit bon voilà votre père est
cliniquement décédé en revanche il a des
organes qui pourrait servir d'autres
gens ce que le problème c'est que votre
père n'a pas émis deux souhaits
concernant le don d'organes
grece alexis papa tu ne l'avais pas dit
ça
le don d'organes et puis et puis le
cercueil qu'on a dû choisir
tu ne vas pas dit non plus épicéa ou pin
des landes 1
et puis lors de la cérémonie funéraire
veux tu qu'on soit triste peut-être et
compris pour toi qu'on pense fort à toi
au contraire qu'on danse autour de ton
cercueil qu'on boive de la bière de la
guinness je ne sais quoi
et puis ah oui j'avais oublié ta vie une
boulangerie non c'était boulanger et
avait une boulangerie on est deux tu as
une boulangerie on est deux comment on
fait le calcul préférées bref on a dû
faire des choix et pour ceux qui n'ont
pas vécu cette expérience je vous
propose une petite comparaison petit
imaginez vous avez une chambre vide il
ya tout à refaire dedans ok donc
quelqu'un de pas très sympa j'insiste
sur ce point vous emmène devant un
énorme magasin de mobilier non pas le
citer le gros truc
ok ils vous emmènent il vous fait sortir
vous fait bon tu choisis ta chambre et
tous par contre ouais t'as une demi
heure là parce que parce que j'ai un
rendez vous alors je sais pas si vous
voyez le truc mort une demi-heure pour
choisir sa chambre n'ont pas fait on
sort de la voiture
on va dans l'axé encore aux concours
parce que vous êtes faut déjà pour
trouver le rayon chambres et une fois
qu'on a trouvé le rayon chambre on prend
le premier league allez on prend le lit
mellouli bon le choisit trop court et
puis ensuite on prend le matelas mais le
matelas ont choisi trop dur et
l'oreiller ont choisi trop nous et la
couverture on arrive tous contents et
puis on se rend compte qu'elle est super
moche et bien si vous voyez un petit peu
si vous êtes représenter un peu la scène
c'est un petit peu l'état dans lequel on
était après le décès de mon père
car vous l'aurez compris
ses choix on n'a pas le temps de les
faire et qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on
doit faire des choix et qu'on n'a pas le
temps de les faire mais on les fait bah
oui en effet mais sans conviction sans
réflexion et on a beau mettre toute la
volonté du monde avec mon frère ouais
vas y arriver et tout c'est bien tout ça
mais la meilleure personne pour avoir
pensé et partager ses choix que nous
devons faire là tout de suite c'est bien
sûr la personne qui est parti c'était
mon père bon je vous rassure je lui en
veux pas du tout un papa tranquille je
pense qu'on a passé un décès on va dire
un deuil convenable vous dire ça comme
ça mais je sais pas pour ceux qui ont
vécu ça mais je pense que c'est assez
générales une fois qu'une personne
proche meurt on a quelques jours pendant
lesquels on peut entièrement se
consacrer à elle complètement
après on retourne à la vie on peut plus
y penser de la même manière et donc ces
petites parties qu'on consacre
entraînement entièrement à la personne
ce précieux temps si on le passe à faire
des choix qu'on a humainement pas le
temps de faire et bien c'est du gâchis
de deuil et rejeté
et c'est vrai j'ai pas très objectif
parce que je parle en tant que vivant
mais parce que selon moi c'est de là que
tout se joue
car nous vivons nous futur morts nous
avons le pouvoir nous pouvons penser à
nos proches à notre famille et nos amis
qui eux resteront une fois que nous
déciderons equihen vivront notre mort le
développement durable de leur deuil se
joue alors vous allez me dire bah ouais
mais comment on fait alors pour en
parler est-ce que tout à l'heure on
avait l'écologie voilà on l'a plus trop
et je suis tombé sur un concept encore
que je trouve génial c'est pas ça
s'appelle le café mortel jianlong j'aime
bien le moins et ça a été inventé par le
philosophe et anthropologue suisse
bernard crettaz et c'est assez simple en
fait c'est un café à manger doute est ce
qu'on veut en fait à des inconnus
et puis on se rencontre et on parle de
tout et de n'importe quoi vis-à-vis de
la mort et on peut très bien imaginer
que pendant une de ces réunions on
puisse aborder la préparation de la mort
tous ensemble et je vous rassure c'est
pas super triste tout le monde chiale et
où j'ai vu des retours et au contraire
il ya de la joie bien sûr il ya des
émotions triste qui passe mais justement
c'est tout ce spectre d'émotions qui
passe dans ce moment dans ce café mortel
et c'est beau et les gens qui sortent de
là ils sont pas tristes ils sont
contents d'avoir fait ça et pour pas
voulu c'est comme ça à l'étape du
discours je vous propose à tous le 7
juin à la maison bleue à 20h première
édition du café mortel a confié vous
êtes tous invités
venez tous trop bien ça va être bien
parce que le développement durable c'est
mortel c'est mortel c'est pour ça que je
vous remercie à tous d'être vivant ici à
m'écouter et je remercierai chaque
personne qui essaiera rien qu'un petit
peu d' apporter sa petite pierre à
l'édifice funéraire afin que les
générations futures mais aussi présente
et passée puisse aborder plus
durablement leur propre mort je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]